I didn't even say Happy New Year's cuz
his New Year's already so did you make
any resolutions
well yes except I did this thing so I
speaking of podcasts I listened to this
podcast called ten things to tell you
and they give you help you with like
setting goals and being mindful in your
life so last year in October she said
how about we set a goal to finish our
new year's resolution for next year by
the end of this year so we start off the
new year in success rather than feeling
like we're in a deficit so I did it you
did I love that I set a goal to
declutter my house and I have three
months to do it October November
December I cleaned out my my garage and
my fav your mail my closet all the
Tupperware and my I feel changed like
it's been a good year and I love doing
that yeah so therapeutic I just go my
closet go don't care don't care don't
care get out of here I'm just looking
yeah yeah I think it's emotionally
helpful I'm going to learn a new
language to learn Spanish 17 years later
Lingle babble I'm trying everything
rosetta stone
none of these know anything you're
helping me I did I got a stone one time
one year I was like I'm gonna learn
French and I got rosetta stone and like
as far as I got was like como be tall
and then I do like an impression which
no one likes I was like and like nobody
nobody once I did French once and all I
got every time was not no no every time
I said it I didn't do not really go no
no I was like you know I hate you
me Francesca and I hate you I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this